un parc à la mémoire de la princesse de
galles inaugurait le jour de son
anniversaire une initiative de son frère
qui a transformé la résidence familiale
en une sorte de diana landes une aide
financière renforcée pour les étudiants
en france un plan du ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui veut également
impliquer les étudiants dans la gestion
des universités l'europe inquiète de la
multiplication de contrefaçons de grande
marque mais aussi de pièces d'outillage
ou d'automobiles qui peuvent mettre en
danger la vie des utilisateurs
hong kong un an après le retour à la
chine le rocher du capitalisme s'ouvre
de la crise financière du sud est
asiatique
mais la chine à respecter son contrat
d'indépendance du monde les français à
la recherche de la concentration avant
le match de vendredi les italiens à la
recherche de toutes les aides possibles
un prêtre accompagne l'équipe madame
monsieur bonsoir il existait des
disneyland il y aura désormais un diana
landes on peut le regretter ou non c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est ouvert un
parc consacré à la mémoire de la
princesse de galles créé par son frère
dans la résidence familiale à une
centaine de kilomètres de long pour
environ 90 francs chaque visiteur pourra
faire le tour du parc mais également
admirer ses plus belles robes et une
exposition des objets qui lui était cher
aujourd'hui jour d'ouverture des
centaines de personnes se pressaient
devant les grilles sur place etienne
leenhardt l'impression que tout
recommence comme au premier jour du mois
de septembre l'année dernière
des bougies les messages des fleurs et
quelques larmes au tour de l'île où est
enterrée la princesse de galles qui
aujourd'hui 1er juillet aurais-tu 37 ans
les 2500 visiteurs qui chaque jour
pendant deux mois se succéderont ici
retrouvent leur reine des coeurs nous
sommes venus pour elle une femme issue
de la noblesse et pourtant si proche du
peuple
j'ai rencontré le comte spencer le frère
de diana
il est absolument charmant j'étais très
triste pour lui c'est une journée
difficile
le voici le comte spencer accueillant ce
matin les premiers visiteurs du musée il
a contrôlé les moindres détails
ses détracteurs le juge mégalomane et en
veulent pour preuve les extraits de son
discours le jour des funérailles
il a fait graver dans la pierre c'est
lui qui a fixé le prix de l'entrée 100
francs par personne dont il promet de
reverser 10% au moins aux organisations
caritatives
le reste les produits dérivés qui ce
matin commencé à se vendre permettront
de rembourser les frais et si d'aventuré
on l'accuse de vouloir tirer profit du
drame familial ils s'insurgent
imaginez quelqu'un gagnant de l'argent
avec la mort de son frère ou de sa soeur
c'est un transfert
je ne connais personne qui en seraient
capables les fidèles de diana venus en
pèlerinage n'avait que faire aujourd'hui
de ces polémiques emportant jalousement
les reliques qui entretiendront le culte
et compte tenu des relations exécrables
entre le comte charles spencer et la
presse anglaise ces questions d'argent
risque à terme de submerger tout le
reste et notamment la réelle émotion de
ceux qui tout l'été viendront rendre
hommage à la princesse de galles
dix mois après sa mort un plan social
pour les étudiants présenté aujourd'hui
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
claude allègre il s'agit d'augmenter et
les moyens financiers mis à la
disposition des étudiants il s'agit
également de leur donner plus de
responsabilités au sein des associations
universitaires jean bernard schmidt
nathalie moisins pour payer ses études
julie a essayé plusieurs petits boulots
des cours particuliers au baby cité
depuis quelques mois elle sert dans un
bar trois nuits par semaine
salaire mensuel 3600 francs compte tenu
des revenus de ses parents julie n'a pas
droit à une bourse
alors elle travaille
et le prix de l'année si on veut vivre
seule en appartement où j'ai trahi à
côté aujourd'hui comme julie près de 40%
des étudiants exercent une activité
professionnelle
le plan social de claude allègre
s'adresse à ces jeunes de condition
modeste
deux cent mille bourses supplémentaires
avec des montants plus élevés de
nouveaux logements étudiants des
réductions dans les transports en commun
des mesures destinées à favoriser
l'autonomie des étudiants ou jette les
bases d'un vrai statut social de
l'étudiant collections est indépendant
et autonome et on considère comme un
adulte à part entière satisfaction donc
côté syndicats mais si les étudiants
considèrent le plan allègre comme un
progrès dans l'amélioration de leurs
conditions de vie beaucoup comme julie
estime qu'il ne résoudra pas tous leurs
problèmes
même si je peux mais nous essayons
bourse même si je bénéficie peut-être un
peu plus de par ce nouvel critères
d'autonomie ça permettra jamais de
subvenir à mes besoins
tous mes besoins qui situe le cou de ma
vie étudiante de tous les jours pour
quitter son travail de serveuse julie
devra donc attendre notamment que claude
allègre et trouver l'argent nécessaire
aux mesures qu'il propose le financement
la principale inconnue de ce plan une
conclusion qui n'est pas très rassurante
au congrès sur la santé publique
a grenoble les jeunes français sont de
plus en plus fragile sur le plan de la
santé en général physique psychologique
une fragilité qui touche surtout les
quartiers dits difficiles pour y
remédier à aubervilliers en banlieue
parisienne a été créé une boutique santé
jeunes benoît thevenet jean-louis me
cet après midi là la discussion s'est
engagée sur l'école c'est le sujet de
préoccupation du moment pour ces ados on
est à mosaïc un centre réservé aux
jeunes est consacrée à leur santé mais
c'est avant tout un lieu des changes
c'est du spontané on fait varier il n'y
a pas de préfabriqués ils viennent
souvent ils viennent avec quelque chose
à dire de qui va bien ou qui va mal ou
de la pluie et du beau temps
il ya des choses qu'on n'ose pas d'armes
par hank con qu'on ose dire aux
animateurs s'efface et c'est ça le plus
déjà mosaïque a été créée par des
professionnels de la santé inquiète des
conséquences de la vétusté du quartier
sur la vie des jeunes l'insalubrité des
appartements est un facteur de risque
pour des maladies comme le saturnisme
mais le premier problème est celui du
manque d'hygiène pas toujours facile à
vivre
moralement les personnes qui vivent dans
ces gens de bâtiments ont souvent peur
de dire que j'habite ici
ou sinon ils se sentent mal dans leur
peau quoi j'avais des problèmes dans la
tête je savais pas pourquoi les avait
menés 6 puis le bien-être des jeunes est
au coeur du fonctionnement de ce qu'ils
appellent la boutique santé ici pas de
consultation médicale mais de la
prévention sexualité alcoolisme
relations avec les parents au suicide
sont abordés au travers de discussions
de livres ou de cd rom les jeunes
peuvent se livrer parler de leur
souffrance ou de leurs désirs le lieu
est reconnue et respectée en deux ans et
demi il n'y a eu aucune dégradation
signe que la confiance s'est installée
le premier ministre annonce ce soir
qu'il retire son projet de réforme du
scrutin pour les élections européennes
un projet qui n'avait reçu que
l'assentiment finalement des socialistes
contesté au sein de la majorité par le
parti communiste et les verts est rejeté
par l'opposition par ailleurs des
premières réactions viennent de tomber
jean louis debré rpr estime que c'est là
un signe clair que monsieur jospin n'a
plus de majorité
quant à françois hollande premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste il estime
qu'il est dommage que la lucidité ne
l'est pas emporté dans cette affaire un
train d'augmentation au 1er juillet
parmi ces hausses de
elle est de moins bonne nouvelle yannick
letranchant +104 francs par mois sur la
feuille de paye des smicards une
augmentation de 2 % pour le salaire
minimum
il passe à 5345 francs nets l'allocation
chômage est également revalorisée +5 9%
certains barèmes de plafonds de
ressources sont revus à la hausse c'est
le cas notamment pour l'accès à un
logement hlm pour un couple de retraités
par exemple ou pour un ménage sans
enfant le plafond passe à 15000 de 138
francs à paris onze 1837 francs province
hausse traditionnelle du 1er juillet
dans les transports parisiens
en ile-de-france la carte orange de zone
augmente de 16 francs
elle passe à 271 francs le coupon 3 5
zones augmente lui de 7 francs en
moyenne
le carnet de 10 tickets de métro ou de
bus passe de 48 à 52 francs le prix du
ticket unitaire ne change pas +0 25%
pour les voitures du nouveau millésime
ce n'est qu'une moyenne certains
constructeurs pratiquant toujours une
politique commerciale de promotion et de
rabais forte explosion s'est tenu à
marseille contre le mur d'enceinte d'un
bureau de poste du centre-ville dégâts
matériels assez importants heureusement
il n'y a pas de blessé les enquêteurs
privilégient la piste des nationalistes
corses habitués à ce type d'action que
dans quelques jours en corse doit
d'ailleurs se tenir un sommet anti
terroriste des principaux responsables
de la police mobilisation aujourd'hui
dans quatre aéroports européens dont
celui d'orly pour sensibiliser les
voyageurs à la contrefaçon qui
représente pour la france une perte
sèche de 40 milliards de francs par an
en termes de chiffre d'affaires et
aujourd'hui cela ne concerne pas
seulement les produits de luxe mais
aussi et pièces automobiles du matériel
destiné à l'aviation de l'outillage avec
cette fois ci donc un danger pour les
utilisateurs ludovic fossat joseph pas
chic
un prospectus pour chaque passager
une manière d'expliquer aux voyageurs
que la contrefaçon coûte 40 milliards de
francs chaque année ça m'arriverait
n'achète pas cher touchant industriel
français qui est attaqué par la
contrefaçon se sont bien sûr le lieu
mais aussi les pièces détachées de
voitures les pièces aéronautiques
le jouet le l'audiovisuel l'informatique
les médicaments les pièces automobiles
sont ainsi de plus en plus contrefaite
moins cher mais surtout moins solide
ce peut être grave même quand il s'agit
d'un simple pare chocs de voitures pour
cette entreprise qui fabrique de
l'outillage en banlieue parisienne
la contrefaçon devient un problème de
plus en plus graves
difficile de reconnaître le vrai du faux
seulement la contrefaçon coûte deux fois
moins cher
elle est beaucoup moins solide c'est une
pâle imitation qui vient de quelque part
en asie et qui ressemble c'est le canada
bras et du tour de vis pas comme c'est
déjà une menace pour nous aussi nous ne
mettions pas un terme
tout ce que nous décelons à tout ce que
nous voyons il est clair que nous
pourrions avoir des produits
contrefaisants les nôtres sur nos
marchés dans les proportions important
les douaniers sont donc de plus en plus
sévères ainsi si vous achetez une
contrefaçon à l'étranger et que vous
êtes contrôlés à l'arrivée vous risquez
de payer une amende équivalente à deux
fois la valeur de l'objet limité à la
veille de l'été des premiers incendies
de forêt à redouter les pilotes de
canadair de la base de marseille
marignane sont en grève depuis presque
trois semaines maintenant ils demandent
une augmentation de leurs frais de
mission yannick aroussi girard gagnant
malgré la grève
ils assurent leur mission cet après midi
avec des pilotes réquisitionné trackers
et canadair ont permis de circonscrire
un incendie près d'aix-en-provence
grâce à l'intervention des moyens
aériens le foehn a parcouru qu'une
douzaine d'hectares
non non non non bien entendu tâche mans
c'est bien on l'a dit
ce matin tous les pilotes ont refusé de
partir en détachement
ajaccio bastia carcassonne ou cannes
notre émission sont largement
insuffisants et nous en avons marre de
continuer à financer ses émissions sur
les forêts l'argent au centre du conflit
les pilotes bombardiers d'eau font un
métier à risque art difficile
ils estiment être les oubliés de
l'aviation surtout en matière de
salaires le pilote de canadair commence
à quatorze mille cinq cents francs et
termine sa carrière à 23 milles francs
si la termine parce que malheureusement
depuis qu'on est là on a perdu 26
copains on perd le prêt un équipage
parents etc peu plus pas été facile dans
man au 20e jour de grève les 88 pilotes
restent fermes sur leurs revendications
l'état lui estime faire de gros efforts
ces 10 h sur le plan salarial des
exigences qui vont quand même un petit
peu au-delà de ce qui paraît raisonnable
disons mais je suis tout à fait prêt à
étudier les conditions dans lesquelles
on pourrait prendre en compte la
situation des personnels qui dans les
services de l'état remplisse chez les
fonctions similaires en présentant
aujourd'hui le plan de lutte contre les
feux de forêt jean pierre chevènement a
souhaité privilégier l'anticipation
ce ne sera possible que si la grève
s'arrête sommes le 1er juillet chaque
année à pareille époque alors que 20
millions de français s'apprête à passer
des vacances sur les côtes
les pouvoirs publics renouvellent leurs
conseils de sécurité de prévention au
bord et sur la mer albon nicosie
emmanuel bec
c'est fou avec un temps pareil on se
croirait presque tenait au mois de
juillet il a fait 31 degrés cet
après-midi sur les plages de marseille
chaque année 20 millions de personnes
fréquentent les côtes françaises pour
elle l'été est synonyme de vacances le
soleil d'insouciance
sécurité sécurité sécurité ici le
crossmed comprendre centre régional
opérationnel de surveillance et de
sauvetage
ici pas de vacances on est 24 heures sur
24 à l'ecoute de tous les incidents en
mer une planche à voile des rives un
voilier se retourne l'appel de détresse
arrive ici
oui pour ce match de quarts bonjour l'an
dernier 4700 personnes ont été secourues
à partir de recherches déclenchées
ici ça peut être des personnes qui ont
loué à un bateau à une date qui malgré
les conditions météorologiques annoncées
et bien prennent quand même le bateau
est près de la mer et donc se met
sciemment en différant position
difficile
sitôt un incident signalé en
méditerranée l'administrateur engage les
moyens les plus appropriés à partir de
ce bâtiment situé non loin de toulon
exemple une vedette des affaires
maritimes croise au large de marseille
la voici saisie de la recherche d'un
scooter des mers ce sera en fait une
fausse alerte comme une fois sur quatre
mais l'occasion de rappeler quelques
règles élémentaires de prudence
vous n'allez pas vous trouver la bague
du grau-du-roi pas mal
l'an dernier 129 personnes ont trouvé la
mort mauvaise météo avarie technique et
quelquefois inconscience
la mer est trop souvent perçu comme un
espace de liberté sans limite
l'europe du marché unique se réalise
jour après jour aujourd'hui ce sont les
transporteurs routiers qui peuvent déjà
sans aucune contrainte s'installer dans
les différents pays de l'union et
transporté désormais des marchandises à
l'intérieur même de chacun de ces pays
les transporteurs routiers français ne
sont pas contre ce qu'ils demandent
c'est une harmonisation des législations
du travail pour que la concurrence soit
réellement équilibrée reportage
dominique barrouche eric de l'agneau
avant d'inonder vos boîtes aux lettres
ces prospectus tout frais imprimés
doivent être livrés chercher le
transporteur routier le moins cher c'est
le travail de christian pradal est son
métier affréteurs même sur de petites
distances comme de torcy à vénissieux
450 km
les étrangers se précipitent
ça nous a beaucoup sortent et on a été
étonné de voir des étrangers nous
pendent des lots au niveau du
nationale des paris douai des paris
verbe événement pour joindre les
transporteurs le téléphone mais surtout
le minitel là une bourse au fret est
ouverte à tous y compris aux routiers
des borgia pour le transport en france
ce qu'on appelle le cabotage pour
christian prat dallest c'est l'occasion
de faire baisser
on a une une comparaison de 10% moins
cher
concernant les étrangers que les
français h
un transporteur de lille nous prendra
donc 10 % plus cher qu'un belges ou
hollandais qui vient sur la frontière de
douai et qui redescend sur paris on le
comprend les transporteurs français
redoutent l'arrivée d'étrangers
il juge la concurrence inégale quand on
prend les espagnols et portugais
il faut avoir le matériel comme il faut
la solution préconisée par la fédération
nationale des transports routiers
harmonisé à bruxelles
elle demande la mise à niveau des
politiques fiscales et sociales à paris
elle réclame des aides pour passer aux
35 heures ainsi qu'un gazole moins taxer
sans être particulière les ventes de
voitures se porte bien cette année en
france en hausse de 9% en juin par
rapport au même mois de l'année dernière
10 % de plus sur les six premiers mois
de cette même année 98
par ailleurs une nouvelle firme
automobile vient s'ajouter à celles
existant déjà l'usiné mercedes d'hambach
en moselle a sorti ce matin ses
premières smart créé par l'inventeur de
la montre swatch avec six mois de retard
dus souvenez vous allez problèmes de
stabilité du véhicule de reportage
christine boss des allures de marier
avec sa robe blanche et son bouquet de
fleurs la première smart faustine et à
la commercialisation est sorti ce matin
de la chaîne de fabrication de hambach
sous les applaudissements du personnel
oubliez les premiers déboires de la
smart recalé en décembre dernier au
fameux test de la baïonnette ou test de
tenue de route
aujourd'hui c'est une voiture revue et
corrigée qui est assemblé sur le site
lorrain en un temps record
de 4h30 techniquement il ya beaucoup de
changements qui ont été faits
là c'est rabaisser les ars ont été
élargies et c'est une meilleure tenue de
route et puis c'est typiquement la
finition des composants aussi qui a été
modifié après six mois d'incertitude les
1500 salariés de mcc des usines
partenaires réunis sur le site baptisé
smart ville sont rassurés et confiants
quant à l'avenir de la microvoiture j'en
suis fier bon je pense qu'elles vont
marcher quoi ça va ça projet et c'est
parti depuis aujourd'hui avec la
production en série qui va augmenter
progressivement nous allons monter en
cadence à partir du 15 juillet pour
arriver à produire 25 mille véhicules à
la fin de cette année et entre 100 et
140 mille véhicules pour l'année
prochaine et jusqu'à 200 mille véhicules
d'ici l'an 2000 à condition que les
clients soient au rendez-vous pour
l'instant 20 me de ces mini voitures ont
été réservées regroupements dans le
secteur de l'assurance s'est finalement
groupama qui a été choisi comme
repreneur de l'assureur public gan qui
doit être privatisée un groupe suisse
était également sur les rangs
le parlement a adopté une nouvelle loi
sur la protection des acheteurs
d'appartements en multipropriété qui
permet je vous le rappelle occuper un
appartement une maison quelques semaines
par an il s'agit de protéger un peu plus
ses acheteurs qui sont parfois victimes
d'escrocs ainsi ils disposeront
désormais d'un délai de réflexion de 10
jours et de conditions d'achat beaucoup
plus précise rivas tio jean pierre papin
s'envoler d'un tenerife pour passer des
vacances dans son appartement
un rêve que permet la multipropriété
quand tout se passe bien grâce à la
nouvelle loi l'acheteur peut se
rétracter dans les dix jours suivant sa
signature des règles précises sont
établis concernant le descriptif des
locaux et la durée des vacances en
france les escroqueries à la
multipropriété sont rares mais attention
aux pièges cachés
au départ ils ont payé une certaine
somme pour acheter son defy est
maintenant avis j'ai ma semaine de
vacances réservé en fait tous les ans et
va leur arriver des charges d'un montant
d'environ selon nos enquêtes de 2000 à
3000 francs pour un deux pièces environ
ensuite ces genres et peuvent ne plus
avoir envie d'aller dans cette résidence
ou d'échangé ou d'avoir ce système de
vacances ou d'avoir un problème familial
professionnel fin porte ils vont vouloir
se séparer de cette semaine de vacances
et l' impossibilité de revente
la loi se conformer à une directive
européenne mais en espagne au portugal
elle ne s'applique pas encore hélas les
arnaques sont légion ces deux retraités
ont versé 75 mille francs pour réserver
une semaine aux canaries
selon le contrat le vendeur devait leur
rendre cet argent au bout de trois ans
promesse non tenue
c'est une bonne nouvelle a fait un super
esprit nos deux retraités ont décidé de
s'éloigner des plages espagnoles et des
propositions de séjours gratuits
cet été direction la bretagne et la
tranquillité des vacances familiales
l'actualité internationale il ya tout
juste un an après 150 années de
colonisation britannique hong kong
retournait à la chine le président
chinois yan pei ming est venu en
personne célébrer ce premier
anniversaire comme promis rien n'a
changé pour hong kong qui conserve son
statut particulier mais l'année n'a pas
été bonne on combres souffre de la crise
financière de l'asie du sud-est isabelle
bechler tristan le bras reportage
depuis la rétrocession de hong kong les
touristes ne se pressent plus dans les
grands vaisseaux dessinée sur mesure
pour 70 % des visiteurs venaient
d'autres pays d'asie et tous ont frappé
de plein fouet par la crise
depuis la rétrocession il est vraiment
beaucoup moins de touristes
nos affaires vont plutôt mal les hôtels
ont été désertés font des rabais toute
épreuve le commerce du luxe s'en ressent
et ce restaurant qui faisait jusqu'à
4000 couverts chaque soir a déjà dû
licencier du personnel
depuis la rétrocession de convient a
chuté c'est à dire au moins 20 pour cent
couverts - la formidable richesse
immobilière du territoire a été
violemment mis à mal par la crise
asiatique les prix très spéculatif est
porté par l'inflation violemment
décroché surtout dans l'immobilier de
bureaux et l'habitat de luxe c'est la
crise financière mais aussi la décision
d'autant que giroix de construire de
l'habitat social qui ont déstabilisé le
marché immobilier les prix sont tombés
d'au moins 20% de fête l'immobilier a
perdu 40 %
'l'indice boursiers lui a fondu de
moitié une bourse tétanisé des sociétés
financières en faillite ou qui
licencient à tour de bras tout la
finance sinistrés les emprunts plus
honorer les crédits devenus impossibles
les capitaux envolé vers des placements
offshore ou vers l'europe
la prospérité n'est plus ce qu'elle
était mais adossé à la chine la monnaie
anglaise a plutôt bien résisté
nous sommes dans une phase extrêmement
difficile qui requiert un ajustement
douloureux comme par le passé je suis
sûr que nous nous en sortirons bien fort
compétitif plutôt la méthode coué ne
suffit pas toujours pour sortir de la
récession d'autant que le chef de
l'exécutif
n'est pas un exemple d'aisance et d'
équilibre vassal de pékin ils veulent
par ailleurs à ce que le système
électoral reste sous le contrôle du
continent qui craint la contagion comme
shirwa oeuvre donc pour que le petit
parlement hong kongais ne soit pas
entraînée vers les rivages démocrates
malgré la très nette majorité remportée
par ceci sous la bannière de l' avocat
martin lee c'était en mai dernier une
victoire marginaliser le système
électoral est conçue contre nous nos
soldats aussi que vous voyez des
démocrates candidats et des démocrates
qui t'engueulent il semble nous sommes
condamnés à occuper une toute petite
minorité de sièges à l'esm ont
maintenant été celle de tous petits
détails ont changé depuis la
rétrocession quelques dispositions
législatives qui ont l'air de ne pas y
toucher une autocensure avérée on
critique de moins en moins pékin où une
plus grande difficulté à prendre des
décisions dans l'administration
autrement dit une lampe est
infinitésimal dégradation plans sont à
peine car hong kong est toujours sur sa
lancée après les accords avec l'ombre et
les élections qui ont suivi première
séance historique aujourd'hui de la
nouvelle assemblée d'irlande du nord à
belfast qui regroupe protestants et
catholiques
le premier premier ministre d'irlande du
nord a été élu il est protestante david
trimble d'âge est de 53 ans il sera
assisté d'un vice premier ministre
catholique pour maintenir la paix en
bosnie l'otan et les nations unies ont
décidé de prolonger le mandat de la
force internationale sur place
trente mille soldats au total parmi 3000
français installés dans la région de
sarajevo principalement et qui après la
guerre continuent leurs actions sous
d'autres formes d'assistance aux
populations reportages géo mni ans
drissa
cette vieille femme serbe a perdu son
fils unique pendant la guerre sa douleur
et celle de centaines de milliers de
bosniaques la perte de l'être cher un
mal dont on ne peut jamais guérir
seulement être soulagé de temps en temps
à coude antidépresseurs comme le prozac
et avec un peu d'humanité
il est important qu'à l'aide matérielle
s'associe également un support un
support moral parfois un geste un
sourire un contact humain avec ces
personnes suffisent à soulager une
partie de leur peine
le docteur leroux conçu de chaque
dimanche dans ce camp de réfugiés où
survivent 800 serbes qui ont dû quitter
sarajevo en 95 à la fin de la guerre ils
n'espèrent plus retourner chez eux faute
de pouvoir y trouver un emploi pourquoi
ne trouvez vous pas de travail à
sarajevo
parce que nous sommes certes retour
improbable des réfugiés n et rancoeurs
de l'après guerre la bosnie vie dans un
calme trompeur ou le mandat des soldats
de l'otan doit être prolongé en
apparence la situation est stabilisée et
c'est un peu une apparence parce que
cette situation est toujours réversible
vous savez qu'ici il y a trois entités
que ces trois entités disposent chacune
de forces armées et disposent chacune de
groupes extrémistes qui sont toujours
décidés a atteint leur objectif
un look à vis de ça chez les réfugiés
les buts de l'équipe yougoslave étaient
perçus comme des buts serbe
les nationalismes sont bien là le
travail de la police internationale avec
ses gendarmes français n'en est que plus
difficile
la police bosniaque opère sous le
contrôle de ces super flics venus de 42
pays différents
nous assurons qu'ils ne commettent pas
d'atteinte aux droits de l'homme en
particulier en termes de violence que la
police travaille au service de la
population et non pas uniquement pour
défendre telle ou telle cause politique
ou idéologique particulière le contrôle
de la police internationale va s'exercer
jusque dans la prison de sarajevo qui
fut pendant la guerre le théâtre de
mauvais traitements chaque détenu qui
est systématiquement entendu et peut
porter plainte pour atteinte aux droits
de l'homme
sur les lignes de démarcation les canons
se sont tus ici le nombre de villageois
a doublé avec les réfugiés de
l'intérieur
l'aide aux populations c'est aussi pour
les troupes françaises
une façon de se faire accepter d'établir
des contacts de sécuriser leur présence
sur le terrain contrairement aux
apparences la paix n'est pas consolidée
ici en bosnie on ne sait pas combien
temps devront rester les troupes de
l'otan
mais une chose est certaine les
populations locales elle ne souhaite pas
le départ des soldats français
en france la commission des droits de
l'homme a demandé à l'institut c'est ça
une enquête un sondage sur le thème du
racisme en france conclusion principale
et biens
18% des personnes interrogées se
déclarent ouvertement xénophobe et 40 %
se disent tentés par le racisme michaël
darmon danier de les tanks est publiée
par le monde souligne trois types
d'attitudes 18% des personnes
interrogées soit près d'un français sur
cinq estiment qu'il ya trop d'étrangers
en france
un deuxième groupe de français reste
proche du premier sur certains thèmes
notamment sur la présence d'arabes et de
noirs
mais se déclare curieusement un peu ou
pas très raciste enfin troisième
catégorie 33 % des électeurs se
déclarant bloc anti raciste dans cette
étude les préférences politiques semble
déterminante les sympathisants de la
gauche plurielle semble nettement
antiracistes comme on le voit sur le
tableau les proches du front national
interrogée s'identifie au groupe à
l'attitude raciste mais fait notable
c'est opinion dépasse l'électorat
lepéniste et se propage dans la droite
un tableau pour le moins inquiétant pour
une enquête aux résultats pourtant
contradictoires en dépit de ceux de ce
paysage général une majorité de français
dit
pourtant on considère une démocratie à
sa capacité d'intégrer les étrangers
pourtant nous faisons confiance à
l'école comme étant une école de
tolérance et un point optimiste en
conclusion les sentiments racistes sont
en baisse depuis sept ans et surtout
chez les jeunes 47 % des moins de 25 ans
se classe parmi les anti racistes dans
cette enquête la coupe du monde de
football des incidents hier soir à la
suite de l'élimination de l'angleterre
par l'argent qu'on à saint-etienne la
justice avec lee continue de frapper
fort les fauteurs de trouble un jeune
stéphanois qui avait agressé un
supporter anglais lundi soir a été
condamné à deux ans de prison ferme pour
extorsion de fonds avec violences
deux ans également pour un anglais qui
avait frappé un policier c'était hier
soir par ailleurs 12 personnes ont été
placées en garde à vue et 700 personnes
delcourt ministère de la justice ont été
interpellées depuis le début de cette
coupe du monde
pour en revenir au football aux sports
la victoire de l'argentine aux tirs au
but a plongé l'angleterre dans la crise
c'est sont sans doute et l'argentine
dans le bonheur laurent frédéric bollée
ils sont revenus dès aujourd'hui à
londres
ils ont même été applaudi pourtant une
défaite de l'angleterre ancienne
championne du monde ça ne passe pas
toujours bien
ainsi un incendie s'est déclaré au siège
de la fédération anglaise de football en
plein coeur de londres
on ne connaît pas encore la cause du
sinistre mais comme on dit il n'ya pas
de fumée sans feu
et depuis hier le vilain petit canard
anglais s'appelle david beckham expulsé
en début de deuxième mi temps il a
contraint ses coéquipiers tenir à 10
contre 11 tout ça pour une réaction
d'orgueil mal placé un coup de pied dans
les jambes d'un argentin alors qu'un
coup-franc venait d'être sifflé en sa
faveur un carton rouge sévère certes
mais pas infondée beckham le beau gosse
fiancé à une des spice girls a tout du
bouc émissaire
usés par leur résistance brave mais
fatigués les anglais au finalement
craqué dans l'épreuve des tirs au but
police a d'abord raté lé 6 1 tandis que
les argentins eux assuré l'essentiel et
c'est paul bhatti finalement qui le
dernier échoue l'angleterre comme en
1986 est éliminée par l'argentine
explosion de joie à saint-etienne et des
mires collectif à buenos aires pour un
peu on pourrait croire que les argentins
sont déjà champion du monde il ya
pourtant encore trois matches à disputer
pour y arriver
des scènes de liesse qui ont fait au
moins 20 blessés et david beckham
l'anglais conscient de ce qu'il a fait
hier soit a présenté ses excuses
publiques à l'angleterre
loin du tumulte à clairefontaine
l'équipe de france prépare son quart de
finale contre l'italie la concentration
est au maximum pour cette finale avant
la finale yann lavoix andré germain
c'est zidane l'âme des bleus avec lui la
france retrouve son chef d'orchestre son
retour pour ce match vendredi est
important autant pour le moral des
joueurs que pour le jeu de l'équipe
il faut qu'ils recherchent à être le
plus décisif possible sur ce match là et
savoir quelle est la qualité technique
extraordinaire qui est à une couverture
de balle extraordinaire qui est une
qualité de passe extraordinaire et qui
sait faire jouer ses partenaires
qui c'est qui s'est animé prendre
comment charles en fait le jeu offensif
et qui l'a démontré en équipe de france
devant tant de compliments zizou baisse
la tête de confusion il connaît sa
valeur et met tout le monde en garde
je vais pas me suis-je tout simplement
un joueur qui certainement a vu ma
position est importante c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que je joue dans un rôle où
je dois mener le jeu est tout simplement
donc je crois que
je crois que c'est un peu pour ça qu'on
connaissait des tic est il a déjà marqué
cinq buts dans cette coupe du monde
christian vieri sera l'ennemi numéro un
des français
agile des deux pieds et de la tête c'est
lui parmi tous les prétendants
prestigieux au poste d'avant centre
qui est le titulaire de la squadra
azzurra et pourtant vieri pas plus qu'un
autre n'aura droit à un traitement de
faveur d'un contre et ronaldo a raconté
tous les plus grands joueurs
jamais on a fait 2 2 de marquage
particulier sur un joueur on a toujours
pris nos joueurs en zone on nous a
plutôt bien réussi puisque tout le monde
ne s'accorde à dire qu'on est quand une
défense assez solide thierry henry était
un entraînement ce matin le monégasque
est simplement couru aux côtés de
dugarry mais il reste un espoir de voir
le meilleur buteur de l'équipe de france
en coupe du monde jouée face à l'italie
barthès lui a préféré interrompre son
entraînement pour ne pas risquer
d'aggraver la contracture qu'il tenait
depuis trois jours allen
pas d'inquiétude néanmoins c'est devenu
un rituel avant chaque rencontre
fabien barthez baisse la tête pour
recevoir le baiser de son copain laurent
blanc pourquoi tant d'amour les membres
al de chez samu porte bonheur c'est vrai
que ça marche du coup le crâne de
barthez est devenu un bisou drôme qui
porte bonheur à toute l'équipe de france
mais les italiens senlis se préparent
également et il met tous les atouts de
leur côté ils sont même assisté d'un
prêtre christelle bertrand pierre
laurent constants
en italie le football est une religion
dieu fait partie de l'équipe pour rester
proche de lui les joueurs ont appelé un
prêtre italien qui vit en france à
l'hôtel il leur dit la messe avant les
matches on célèbre la messe là dans la
femme de jeu là où diane le biais d'ubs
box un prêt de fans de foot
si forcément indulgent pour les petits
blasphème j'ai eu une oreille sélective
de parce que je veux reprendre de toute
chanson et à la fin on donne là une
solution générale
parfois dans un match il y à des
miracles et voilà la main de dieu à
aider celles du gardien les prières des
joueurs ont été exaucées on était
content après les bons façonner le
mental et le jt de les chapeaux ce que
je fais ce ballon qui nous aurait fait
beaucoup de mal le père concini célèbre
une messe pour eux le samedi ou le
dimanche les joueurs ne se confesse pas
mais ils ont des prières bien
particulière elles m'ont demandé des
prêts pour qu' il n'est pas des
d'accident grave et qu'elle est ce soit
un beau match de foot qu'on puisse qu'il
puisse donner le mail & mail de même sur
la scène du mondial les apôtres de
maldini ont mis tous les atouts de leur
côté
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour battre
la france dieu seul le sait il ya un
journal qui en ce moment bat tous les
records de diffusion et de vente c'est
l'équipe le seul quotidien français
entièrement consacré au sport chaque
soir les journalistes de l'équipe
réalise des prouesses pour offrir aux
lecteurs
les commentaires les plus chauds sur les
événements de la veille qui se terminent
souvent très tard comme ce fut le cas
hier soir
thibault de barbeyrac josé boulesteix
la tante infernale 23h46 hier pour les
argentins
c'est le soulagement soulagement aussi
dans l'atelier du journal l'équipe en
banlieue parisienne
normalement à cette heure ci le journal
est déjà bouclé ce soir le titre est
prêt mais on attendait le nom du
vainqueur pour qu'il figure sur la une
une demi heure de retard ce sera sans
conséquence pour la distribution dans
l'équipe quatre heures plus tôt comme
dans un vestiaire avant un match
à la rédaction on donne les dernières
consignes à l'autre bout du fil
l'un des cinq envoyés spéciaux du
journal à saint-etienne ce soir il aura
un oeil sur la pelouse
l'autre sur son clavier aux d'ailleurs
qu'un match à 21h quasiment à part le
premier quart d'heure de chaque mi-temps
on peut avoir un oeil
assez assez pointue il est clair
qu'avant lui en donner pour prendre dans
l'ordinateur et on fait beaucoup les
matchs à l'oreille
et puisque les envoyés spéciaux écrit
pendant le match à paris une trentaine
de journalistes relisent leurs articles
et vérifie qu'il n'y ait ni erreur ni
oubli des journalistes passionnés de
foot qui vivent la coupe du monde dans
un bureau c'est surtout quand je dis à
mes amis ma famille la coupe du monde tu
vas suivre les matchs que tu vas suivent
l'angleterre et tissage famille je suis
l'angleterre mais chez la coupe du monde
à paris puis je suis le tour de france
après mes périodes qui s'est
complètement frustrant mais bourse pour
l'événement les effectifs de la rubrique
football ont été triplées ils sont 75
chaque jour ils écrivent l'équivalent
d'un livre de poche de 150 pages
leur but être exhaustif on a des
journées ski sont spécialisés sur toutes
les grandes équipes et on essaye d'être
aussi fort sur la photo est aussi riche
dans le magazine sur chacun des pays
l'équipe le journal d'information et
journal d'opinion depuis trois ans aimé
jacquet est critiquée à longueur de
colonnes et aujourd'hui malgré les bons
résultats de l'équipe de france la
virulence contre le sélectionneur
continue
je crois qu'on sait moins tromper qu est
beaucoup moins tromper tués
et que on fera les comptes ensuite c'est
la france est championne du monde on
aura l'air de s'être trompée je crois
qu'on ne sera pas trompés parce qu'elle
est championne du monde sait qu'elle a
joués et qu'elle a fait ce qu'on dit
depuis trois ans on l'aura compris ici
on ne pratique ni diplomatie ni modestie
de plus victoire au nom de la france en
finale l'équipe affichera des records de
vente
tout bénef n'y aura que vers tasse à
l'ombre du mondial wimbledon le tournoi
de tennis anglais se poursuit avec une
belle performance de la française
nathalie tauziat qui s'est qualifié pour
les demi finales en battant aujourd'hui
en deux sets secs
l'américaine lindsay davenport en demi
finale dosière rencontrera la biélorusse
s'est encore deux images l'etna le
volcan italien et s'est réveillé il est
en prêt et dans une nouvelle période
d'activité et spectaculaire vous le
voyez heureusement sans dommage
désormais pour les populations qui
vivent aux alentours
mais les fics et puis une vente record à
londres
un collectionneur anonyme s'est offert
un monet pour 174 millions de francs
qu'il pourra accrocher chez lui le
bassin aux nymphéas réalisé dans le
jardin même du peintre 7 et à giverny
dans leur 174 millions de francs pour ce
bouquet de fleurs avant nous quitter le
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité d'abord une aide de
financier renforcé pour les étudiants en
france un plan du ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui veut également
appliquer ces étudiants dans la gestion
des universités et des écoles
le premier ministre annonce ce soir
qu'il retire son projet de réforme du
scrutin pour les élections européennes
un projet qui n'avait reçu que
l'assentiment des socialistes contesté
au sein de sa majorité par le parti
communiste et les verts est rejetée
globalement par l'opposition voilà dans
un instant la météo sophie davant je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
notre chaîne bonsoir allemand